JJ won't brush out - JJ one who gets
hurt every year I'm sending this in to
get a little relationship advice I've
been dating my girl for about four
months now
amen and her parents don't want us to
date because apparently I'm not a
devoted Christian ah so I'm wondering
what you guys think I should do keep
sneaking around with her like we have
been the last couple months or just
break things off before we get too much
further let me know gang gang butt plug
oh he's into the dark arts I wouldn't
let my daughter hang out with that guy
either when it was the Christian comic
John Christ dude do what John Christ did
just fake the funk bro and boss not dude
just just by [ __ ] Kanye's new Yeezy
season seven like his friend and pretend
you're religious dude and then you marry
girl and she knows what's up she's
obviously cool you don't know what
[ __ ] John palm 17 is or whatever it's
Psalms first of all okay dude palms is a
pornstar that's how I know okay dude buy
some [ __ ] Stone Cold Steve Austin
shirts with the [ __ ] 3:16 on it but
never know dude just wow
funk you can hear the votes adding up
for who's going to hell can't you can't
you just hear the votes adding up your
spirit is in the drain brother have you
have you did you grow up going to church
yeah not a time but I went sometime my
dad was a favorite for huh god is great
God is good God we thank you for this
food here bro eyes hands we our faith
like you look for daily bread
come on man you gotta tighten up dawg
are you gonna freakin you know where you
gonna end up I wanna be there bro I love
you you way to hug me Nelly bro it's
gonna be dude it's gonna be you boy
they gonna be noodle in a bunch of old
men noodle in you I'm saying bro you
gotta tighten up this guy this is a good
question man this is a real good
question
you're young dude if you love or fake
the funk you don't know them [ __ ] dude
well yeah it's true it's not thing also
if the real Christians they shouldn't be
judging you either for the probably them
fake-ass Christians okay I know I'm
digging myself deeper to hell you should
forgive pammi your shovel man pull my
shovel um I don't know man
this is it here's the thing if her
parents if that's what they want it's
like it I could imagine if I'm a parent
and the kid is like but you seem like a
nice kid this guy seems like a nice cool
yeah yeah he's got braces dude that's
brave as [ __ ] to wear braces metal ones
yeah 19 year but you Bay do you [ __ ]
you're basically the Flavor Flav of our
generation dude if you [ __ ] wearing
that it's crazy that's brave as [ __ ]
dude you're like basically the Forrest
Gump of [ __ ] grills you a young
carrot top as proton same right that's a
mean [ __ ] do either bobby schmurder of
your generation if you wear [ __ ]
metal braces but you like a white
Takashi six minutes bro well every other
[ __ ] is is doing these you know there's
a line mail or something somebody
dude a buddy of mine got the wrong one
sent oh dude he looks like a senior
citizen yeah ro it's insane all it takes
is one [ __ ] Amazon mix-up because
your [ __ ] delivery dudes too high and
next thing you know you got the teeth of
a [ __ ] newborn [ __ ] kitten
you know she's kidding you know you have
the teeth of a crocodile it takes you a
minute and a half to smile because you
got 2,000 [ __ ] teeth bro so that's
what I'm saying dude mad respect you for
stick keeping it old school and keep it
that's like Kevin the Jordan ones on
your [ __ ] smile man look it's obvious
you care about the girl cuz you're even
caring about this question man I think
you could present to the to the parents
look you know I don't know how I feel
you know like I'm doing the best that I
can I do not care about your daughter
and then let them deal with that at that
at that point because if that's you if
that's your truth if you're just trying
to [ __ ] man and that's a different story
but I would just I don't know man I
don't even know Brendon Oh Christian
catfished this [ __ ] yeah what is out
you're young dude kind of read up a
little bit by the Bible for dummies read
up a little bit let the pimps you know
know what's up you're not gonna marry
the bra dude you're sixteen with braces
no of your life bro you ain't going to
hell I challenge you to marry her dude I
don't don't do that
Bernie's a [ __ ] bro no I'm not uh-huh
watching one healthy relationship listen
listen to your boy okay keep the braces
you got me with that one if you can do
braces these days metal braces you could
do a marriage bro you mean your braces
you can do anything bro it's like
putting races on your wiener bro you
know you could do a marriage easy dude
and plus if you have a couple of kids
but in a church family there's nothing
they love more when you throw a few kids
in their child yeah they love that [ __ ]
what do you think about this Derek you
regnant yeah Derek I know this is
probably your I'm a baby man pretend to
be Christian bro everybody else is doing
it we're never gonna be all of us are
fuck-ups man you know what I'm saying we
just try our best I'll forgive
I know I shall forgive I'm trying to
forget thou shalt not kill
alright thou shalt forgive thy shall
bust not in line of the true word of
Jesus Christ Rowley that's a [ __ ]
dart game man it's a dart game out there
religion to the darkest game religion is
a dark game man we took my world
religions done over all the day about
people fighting for religion there's
more people than anything else people
believe in their faith though man people
believe in it yeah you know it's wild
whatever get you through the day bro
well here's the thing man I believe in
faith but I don't believe I'm not gonna
take a sword to somebody if they don't
believe what I believe that's crazy
especially what I'm still figuring out
what I believe you know mm-hmm we'll
fight and sword and I don't I need some
evidence bro you got a look in your
heart for that man yeah I guess science
bro there's a little box of my lambo for
it that's me caught us on it's on wheels
what do you think about this kid what do
y'all think about this kid let's go to
the culture corner man we don't know
[ __ ] Brendon I like him Andy he's a
cutie he's a youngster you know what I
mean ho ho he's like 14 Oh pastor Poston
[Laughter]
what would you do cat I mean he's 16
white why is he talking to her parents
I've never talked to any of the parents
of the guys I've dated in high school
really interesting that's very
interesting
why not that I definitely had to deal
with some parents I wasn't allowed to
have a boyfriend growing up I wasn't
allowed to have friends and 12 like in
college my mom did not want me to have
well then this is perfect in for you so
what so what we imagine if this was your
boyfriend in high school or something
and this is the question he sends in you
know I like cat let's go let's play it
back and we'll put cat in there what's
up Theo what's up Brendon
I'm sending this in to get a little
relationship advice I wonder who he's
seeing I've been eating my girl for
about four months okay pause it
and her parents he's girl whoo
cat hmm he's dating Kat for months
Wow for four months this guy really
cares about her it seems like her it
looks like he's in a church when he's
sent in this yeah it does
confession booth the thing is is four
months in his little lifetime that's
forever
yeah they got rings and [ __ ] it's like
5% of his life yep 16 if I was dating a
guy for four months I wouldn't bring him
to anything I'd only hang out with him
in private Kat is a savage hey Siri
what's 16 times 12 so four months of 192
that's basically it's like 2% of his
life he spent with with cats a lot of
time cat that's not enough time for me I
would not have had brought him to my
parents okay but this is how he's
feeling so you don't even give a [ __ ]
about him so let's imagine that now so
the guy cares
you don't care let's keep playing I
don't want us to date because apparently
I'm not a devoted Christian what's that
easy these days wondering what you guys
think I should do keep sneaking around
with her like we have been for the past
couple months or just break things off
before we get too much further let me
know Gang Gang butt plug that's why I
can't get you in the house brother the
butt plug beam ain't gonna get you in
the Lord's house Derek flared up when he
heard it no no no house either pastor P
to make him say God if this was me I
feel like I would have told my parents
there's this guy who has a crush on me I
don't want to spend any more time with
him can you please make up an excuse for
why we can't see each other cuz he's not
taking a hit oh wow if that was me yeah
cuz that's the problem we don't get here
is we don't get what the I know yeah we
need the other girl I wish we get both
sides I need more facts well here's what
we can do we can ask him said hey you
know December 14
I need all information
that's a better requested not pics of a
fourteen-year-old girl it's your time
not do I seem too much euphoria bro for
our show I don't think we have insurance
dude - do not send pics do not sympathy
learn us man are we on the holiday you
might be 21 no he said I would he is did
he didn't know you didn't know that's
never mind there's a again I need more
info stem pics
sim pics of anyone that's over 18 man
yeah but here's the thing bro I think if
we could get her take on this I think
we'd be able to maybe give a better
suggestion you never get the woman's
take do it but that's the problem
sometimes with Sookie wish yeah it's
like with people looking for advice or
suggestions they can't well here's the
problem or crowds real [ __ ] fest I don't
think it is we get a lot of females do
we I think so well for a flop my on know
they send only promises all the girls
are sending stuff they just they just
send in like a what up the oh well you
must be using a for something cuz I've
never seen one of those pictures let me
tell you some if you get one of those if
you get a few of those run it by us I
don't need a man I'm trying to keep I'm
trying to I've enough problem dude I see
something I'll think about man qinger
staying at my [ __ ] or my butt hole and
I'm like whoa lady we use it all right
well good luck to this guy man do the
Lord's work in life wow man I'm gonna
say look man I think you know I think
pray if you really care about it
presented to her folks and say look this
is how I feel about your daughter
you know if I'm not religious enough for
you or something this or play he'll tell
me you believe in voodoo see how it goes
dude no I like that too bro if you want
me boss and your [ __ ] drew brees
Jersey dog and telling them you know put
some dad put some [ __ ] dead squirrel
skeletons around your neck tell me
believe in the dark arts Brodie I knew a
guy who used to sell aah aah raccoon
penis necklaces dude I'd buy one swear
to god this dude outside of Iowa oh yeah
I'd buy one so and outside of why I'll
buy ya outside of Iowa but what else
would I do good luck
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]